[Music]
can you take this away you want to do
nice one one way you can share this
service
all right thank you very much everybody
for standing by until this moment to
hear the outcome of the Emergency
Committee on the 2019 novel coronavirus
meeting very glad to have here with me
on the podium professor did you sir was
the chair of the Emergency Committee
welcome dr. Ted Rose along with Mrs W
director-general dr. Mike Ryan executive
director for health emergencies at WHL
dr. marathon care Kofi acting head for
emerging diseases in so gnosis welcome
to all of you for those online please
dial zero one on your keypad for
questions we will start with
director-general dr. Ted rose to give a
short announcement then we'll hand over
to Professor Musa afterwards we'll have
time at this point
for a very limited amount of questions
we'll take two from the room and two
from the phones I know there are many
more questions but please bear with us
this has been a very long day so for the
panel here please we need to share those
best microphones to get everybody on on
the line also to hear us
thank you very much in the hand over to
dr. tetras not only a long day by the
way Tarek I mean Christian it's the
default it's the default it's also a
long week since last Thursday how many
times have we met
so it must be tired of us and so we will
make it brief that's why and apologies
also for keeping you waiting and good
evening to everyone in the room and to
everyone online over the past few weeks
we have witnessed the emergence of a
previously unknown pathogen which has
skated into an unprecedented outbreak
and which has been met by an
unprecedented response as I have said
repeatedly since my return from Beijing
the Chinese government is to be
congratulated for the extraordinary
measures it has taken to contain the
outbreak despite the severe social and
economic impact those measures are
having on the Chinese people we would
have seen many more cases outside China
by now and probably does if it were not
for the government's efforts and the
progress they have made to protect their
own people and the people of the world
the speed with which China detected the
outbreak isolated the virus sequenced
the genome and shared it with whu-oh and
the world are very impressive and beyond
words
so is China's commitment to transparency
and to support in other countries in
many ways China is actually setting a
new standard for outbreak response and
it's not an exaggeration
I also offer my profound respect and
thanks to the thousands of brave health
professionals and all frontline
responders who in the midst of the
Spring Festival are working 24/7 to
treat the sick save lives and bring this
outbreak under control thanks to their
efforts the number of cases in the rest
of the world so far has remained
relatively small there are new there are
now 98 cases in 18 countries outside
China including 8 cases of human to
human transmission in 4 countries
Germany
Japan Vietnam and the United States of
America so far we have not seen any
deaths outside China for which we must
all be grateful although these numbers
are still relatively small compared to
the numbers of cases in China we must
all act together now to limit further
spread the vast majority of cases
outside China have a travel history to
ohan or contact with someone with a
travel history to ohan we don't know
what sort of damage this virus could do
if it were to spread in a country with a
weaker health system we must act now to
help countries prepare for that
possibility for all of these reasons I
am declaring a public health emergency
of international concern over the global
outbreak of novel : of a corona virus
the main reason for this declaration is
not because of what is happening in
China but because of what is happening
in other countries our greatest concern
is the potential for the virus to spread
to countries with weaker health systems
and which are ill prepared to deal with
it let me be clear this declaration is
not a vote of no-confidence in China
on the contrary whu-oh continues to have
a confidence in China's capacity to
control the outbreak I'll repeat this
let me be clear this declaration is not
a vote of no-confidence in China
on the contrary whu-oh continues to have
confidence in China's capacity to
control the outbreak as you know
I was in China just a few days ago where
I met with President Xi Jinping I left
in absolutely no doubt about China's
commitment to transparency and
protecting the world's people to the
people of China and to all of those
around the world who have been affected
by this outbreak we want you to know
that the world stands with you we're
working diligently with national and
international public health partners to
bring this outbreak under control as
fast as possible in total there are now
seven thousand eight hundred thirty-four
confirmed cases including seven thousand
seven hundred thirty-six in China
representing almost 99% of all reported
cases worldwide 170 people have lost
their lives to this outbreak all of them
in China we must remember that these are
people not numbers more important than
the declaration of a public health
emergency are the committee's
recommendations for preventing the
spread of the virus and ensuring a
measured and evidence-based response I
would like to summarize those
recommendations in seven key areas first
there is no reason for measures that are
necessarily interfere with international
travel and trade so whu-oh doesn't
recommend limiting transfer or thread
and and movement we call on all
countries to implement decisions that
are evidence-based and consistent WHS
stands ready to provide advice to any
country that's considering which
measures to take second we must support
countries with weaker health systems
third accelerate the development of
vaccines therapy
ethics and diagnostics forth combat the
spread of rumors and misinformation
fifth review preparedness plans identify
gaps and evaluate the resources needed
to identify isolate and care for cases
and prevent transmission sixth share
data knowledge and experience with
whu-oh in the world and seventh the only
way we will defeat this outbreak is for
all countries to work together in a
spirit of solidarity and cooperation
we're all in this together
and we can only stop it together this is
the time for facts not fear this is the
time for science not rumors this is the
time for solidarity not stigma I thank
you thank you very much dr. Ted Rose and
that's here from the chair of the
Emergency Committee professor who seen
thank you very much so now was the the
time today the Emergency Committee
almost unanimously concluded that it was
now time to suggest to the DG of WH show
that the novel coronavirus outbreak is a
public health emergency of international
concern considering first the increase
in the number of cases in China second
the increase in the number of countries
affected with cases and also that some
countries have taken questionable
measures concerning travellers thanks to
the ihr our main international health
treaty declaring a public health
emergency of international concern is
likely to facilitate wh show leadership
leadership role for public health
measures holding countries to account
concerning additional measures
they may take regarding travel trade
quarantine or screening research efforts
global coordination and anticipation of
economic impacts support to vulnerable
States Declaration of a fake should
certainly not be seen as a manifestation
of distrust in the Chinese authorities
and people which are doing tremendous
efforts on the front line of this
outbreak with transparency and let us
hope with success novel coronavirus has
placed its crown in several countries
some are able to try to cope with new
cases for some others it will be more
difficult and declaration of a public
health emergency of international
concern
should open ways to facilitate this task
the DG just declared the novel
coronavirus event as a public health
emergency of international concern for
these purpose the Emergency Committee
has formulated advices that could become
temporary recommendation concerning
w-h-o China and affected or non affected
countries and this will be detailed in
the statement about public health
measures Travel Research international
cooperation and coordination thank you
thank you very much professor houssam
now we're opening the floor here in the
room for two questions and then we will
go online so then I'll take the first
year from the Chinese college please
introduce yourself as young with Xinhua
News Agency I got two questions for
director-general first one to your
knowledge what are the most extreme
extreme measures that some other
countries may execute against the China
after the release of the decision and
how will W ratio respond to it to these
drastic measures
secondly as many countries are stepping
up to work on the the vaccine so what
kind of role can waho play in
coordinating international efforts to
work and develop the vaccine and is
there a specific timeline for the
development of the vaccine thank you
thank you
as I said it earlier we should have
actually express our respect and
gratitude to China for what it's doing
it has already done incredible things to
limit the transmission of the virus to
other countries and where respect is due
then you don't punish meaning if anyone
is thinking about taking measures it's
going to be wrong and whu-oh doesn't
recommend and actually opposes any
restrictions for travel and trade or
other measures against China on the
vaccine we have already started and we
have in the invited relevant partners
and there is progress and we will inform
you as soon as we have you know detailed
information thank you and I'll take a
second question from room Associated
Press please
connealy hi this is Jamie from
Associated Press dr. Tetris thank you
very much um two quick questions one is
um I'm not quite sure about the travel
recommendations it sounds like you and
dr. sell are saying different things the
wh o is not recommending a travel
recommendation but that countries
themselves should be allowed to so how
does that all fit together cuz as you'd
know there are a lot of countries that
are already reacting and then the second
question just has to do with your visit
to xi Jinping I just want to make sure
that we understand when the last time
that a DG like you I'm flew to a country
to meet with a head of state during an
evolving outbreak to request more debt
more detailed data and permission why
was that necessary and if China was
responding efficiently in transparency
if China was responding transparently
and efficiency why was that necessary
thank you yeah I would be happy to give
that travel we don't recommend travel or
trade restrictions as whu-oh and what I
said and what Professor who's said are
actually the same but I would be glad if
professor also can comment on that and
on my trip to China I have done it to
other countries too before so you know
going to the field visiting countries
you know having first-hand information
is very important and that's why I had
to visit to see for myself
what's happening and I came back so
impressed I have never seen in my life
this kind of mobilization and maybe
you're following the one hospital which
is being built in ten days
big Hospital but that's not the only
thing you know the measures they are
taking which I believe will reverse the
tide and going there and witnessing that
is very important witnessing how the
leadership is leading the response is
very important and the other impressive
part is it's the President himself who
is leading this effort and when we
arrived that day we arrived the Prime
Minister was actually in in Wuhan and
all the ministers are involved with
relevant ministers this is impressive
and witnessing that kind of leadership
and interacting with those leaders were
leading an outbreak personally can get
me a real experience for me too and
actually a learning experience and
because of that I actually recommend it
to other countries globally to have that
kind of political commitment and
leadership at the highest level possible
and when that happens I know things
happen on the ground too so I think
visiting China was a very important one
which is not a new one of course I did
it many times to other countries where
there was outbreaks and and and so on
this one was special because I was able
to learn many things from what China is
doing and I'm very confident by what
they are doing I have seen the capacity
and and I believe that they will control
this outbreak as soon as possible they
have all the capacity that that needs
but not only what they're doing is
protecting their people but I know from
the figures also you know that it's
protecting the rest of the world
outside China we only have 98 cases and
notice if strong measures were not taken
in China this would not have happened
and that's why I also said we have to
appreciate what China is doing and this
declaration is not actually because
China is not doing what it it can it's
actually doing more than China is
required to do this is to protect
especially countries with weaker health
system and to prepare for that and for
your information during my discussion
with the President and other officials
they are willing to support countries
with weaker health systems with whatever
is possible I think that is why I said
in my speech earlier in many ways China
is actually setting a new standard for
outbreak response thank you looking at
professor Sephora for comments on
prevalent recommendation what is what
does it mean a travel restriction it
means for example visa refusal board a
closure a quarantine of travelers who
are in good condition
these travel restrictions under the
declaration of a public health emergency
of international concern
they will this declaration will provide
to w-h-o the possibility to question
such measures which already have been
taken by some by some countries why did
you take this decision why what is the
science supporting this decision could
you reconsider this decision and we
suggested to whu-oh that whu-oh should
inform the world about
Transparency concerning these measures
which should not constitute an example
to follow but a decision to reconsider
thank my professor who start with this
will turn towards our journalist
colleagues on the line by the way we
have more than 150 online right now I'm
looking at Radio France for the first
question and then we will go to science
microfiche myths the radio france please
first visit for dr. precipitates or his
evacuation family mutagenesis 20-piece
pass certainty but hope increases
evacuation is surely less than usual on
rebukes you don't to initiate a miss
Cooper 6e no city Mizuki so Panasonic if
only first merci BR but could you please
repeat for the journalists in the room
and our listeners to see a question in
English thank you of course the question
was about the evacuation and that was
taken from certain countries among them
France do you consider that it is an
unnecessary measure and also the fact
that some some some countries again
France like you have no direct flight
now from air falls from Paris to to
China do you consider those measures
unnecessary - thank you the evacuations
from the citizens of some countries who
are presently in the Hubei Province they
are measures that some countries are
able to take because they have the
capacity to do it logistically speaking
they also are the proof of some
confidence in the capacity they are then
to to avoid contamination from this
persons once they have returned on the
on their national in their national
state so this is why it is a measure
that some countries are able to take but
clearly not all countries can do that
it's probably a situation which is a
little bit exceptional this this is the
only thing I can say about that thank
you very much I hope with this address
please I think we we will do everything
so people can do the right things with
the flights we may not be able to
convince them because some of the
airlines actually said that they're not
flying it's not because of the virus
because they don't have enough
passengers and that could be a reason
and will be very difficult if that's the
case otherwise we engage and through
this declaration by the way through the
recommendations we accept that they will
we expect that they will follow that but
at the same time we will continue to
engage thank you thank you much
gentlemen ladies on the panel with this
we reached the end of press printing
everybody thank you very much to all the
many listeners online and to the large
crowd here in the room
I thank the panel thank you all very
much for everybody we will be sending
the audio files very shortly after this
together with this statement and the
intervention by dr. Ted Rose and
sometime later maybe also video clips
and for the transcript we will most
likely only send in the course of
tomorrow thank you all very much have a
good evening thank you
I helped my friends by semester and my
family they did much worse in China it's
very expensive so one little pack mess
more than 100 RNG
here is a much cheaper and easier to buy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]